The superhero genre has taken over the film
industry in recent years, thanks in no small
part to the spectacular action sequences at
the core of the movies.
The impending release of Batman v Superman:
Dawn of Justice looks to continue that trend,
as it features what might be the most anticipated
superhero brawl of all time.
With the release of Captain America: Civil
War also in our very near future, we decided
to collect our favorite jaw dropping brawls
from the cinematic worlds of Marvel, DC, and
everything in between.
In no particular order, here are Screen Rant’s
10 Mind Blowing Fights in Superhero Movies.
SPIDERMAN VS.
GREEN GOBLIN
The web crawler’s big screen debut launched
the superhero genre to new heights when it
became the first film in history to cross
the $100 million threshold in its opening
weekend at the box office.
Featuring a star making performance from Tobey
Maguire — as well as a wonderfully hammy
villainous turn by Willem Dafoe — this breakout
hit crescendo in gritty fashion with a third
act showdown between the two arch nemeses.
After managing to subdue the crazed Norman
Osborn, a badly injured Spiderman dodges an
underhanded glider attack at the last second,
and the Goblin pays the ultimate price for
his treachery.
BIG DADDY VS.
WAREHOUSE THUGS
Kick Ass had no shortage of insane fight sequences,
and the ones featuring Chloe Moretz’s Hit
Girl were as fun and inventive as killing
sprees get, but it was Big Daddy’s warehouse
sequence that truly sent a chill down our
spine.
Nicholas Cage’s performance as a murderous
masked vigilante was as over the top as you
might expect, and his showdown with mobster
Frank D’Amico’s men was a particularly
violent visual treat.
Set to the tune of John Murphy’s epic instrumental
track “In the House — In a Heartbeat,”
Big Daddy runs through the thugs with the
sort of brutal efficiency that would make
Batman himself proud.
Except for the killing part.
THE PUNISHER VS.
THE RUSSIAN
The second of three attempts to bring the
fan favorite antihero to life on the big screen
did not fare well, critically or financially.
Despite an admirable effort from star Thomas
Jane, the film simply didn’t connect with
audiences.
One of the lone bright spots of this grim
affair was this 4+ minute long brawl between
Frank Castle and The Russian, a mob enforcer
played by Kevin Nash.
The 6’9 former professional wrestler brings
a true sense of physicality to the scene,
and even though the fight has its silly moments,
it’s still one of Marvel’s most memorable
showdowns.
Keep an eye out for an even more badass Punisher
in season 2 of Daredevil.
QUICKSILVER VS.
PENTAGON SECURITY TEAM
Comic book fans were up in arms when the design
of Evan Peters’ Quicksilver was initially
unveiled on the cover of Empire Magazine.
Despite bearing little resemblance to his
comic book counterpart, the speedster ended
up stealing the show with this innovative
slow-mo sequence.
Folk legend Jim Croce’s “Time in a Bottle”
echoes in the background as “Peter” Maximoff
cleverly maneuvers the room at supersonic
speeds, dispatching of the security guards
and preventing his fellow mutants from being
riddled with bullets.
Fingers crossed X-Men: Apocalypse features
more highlight reel Quicksilver scenes like
this one.
OZYMANDIAS VS.
NITE OWL II AND RORSCHACH
Despite any criticisms cinephiles may level
at Batman v Superman director Zack Snyder,
it’s an indisputable fact that the man can
helm an action sequence like few others in
the industry.
Fans got a taste of what they can expect out
from his Dark Knight’s fighting style in
this underrated 2009 adaptation of Watchmen.
The film features a few solid brawls, but
the final showdown between Nite Owl II, Rorschach,
and the mass murdering Ozymandias is particularly
stellar.
The latter’s gradual reveal of his plot
to kill millions during the fight is a bit
of an eye roller, until he mentions the fact
that the deed is already done and there truly
is no stopping him.
CAPTAIN AMERICA VS.
THE WINTER SOLDIER
Easily one of the best films to come out of
the Marvel Cinematic Universe so far, Steve
Rogers’ second solo outing was a thrill
ride from start to finish.
It’s almost unfair to single out one solitary
moment from the movie, but in our eyes, the
highway fight scene between the Captain and
his former best friend turned assassin takes
the cake.
This expertly choreographed super soldier
melee is capped off by the film’s big reveal
— that Bucky Barnes is still very much alive
— one that adds an extra dimension to the
proceedings.
These two look to be fighting on the same
side again in Civil War, but we wouldn’t
be opposed to another physical altercation
or two.
BATMAN VS.
BANE
Having appeared in more live action films
than any other modern superhero, you’d think
we’d have gotten a proper fight sequence
featuring the Caped Crusader before 2012.
Widely hyped as the first time we’d see
the Batman taking on a worthy physical foe
on the big screen, his first battle against
Bane was a shocker for non comic fans who
never thought they’d see the Dark Knight
get manhandled like this.
Fans of the 1993 Knight fall storyline probably
saw the back break coming a mile away, though.
Batman of course manages to heal himself and
overcome his foe in the end, though not before
he was betrayed in epic fashion by the shadows
he once believed to be his and his alone.
IRON MAN VS.
THE HULK
The sequel to one of the most successful movies
of all time, Age of Ultron had an absurd standard
to live up to.
And while it may not have improved on its
predecessor in any meaningful way, Whedon’s
Avengers follow up was still a smash hit with
critics and audiences alike, thanks in no
small part to this spectacular brawl.
Fans had hoped to see Iron Man break out the
Hulk buster armor for years, and its live
action debut did not disappoint.
Tony Stark’s upgraded suit eventually stops
the rampaging behemoth, but not before the
two tear apart a Wakandan city.
Black Panther’s probably not going to be
too thrilled about that when he makes his
debut in Civil War.
SUPERMAN VS.
GENERAL ZOD
Zack Snyder’s second scene on this list
is also quite possibly the most controversial.
While few would argue against the sheer visual
spectacle of watching two Kryptonians beat
the hell out of each other, the fact that
Metropolis was all but leveled in the process
bothered a lot of comic book fans.
And even more were upset over Superman’s
decision to kill Zod in order to save the
lives of innocent bystanders.
Both the battle and its murderous conclusionary
act will have MAJOR consequences in Batman
v Superman, of course.
In fact, they could just be leading directly
into the most epic superhero battle of all
— though the jury’s still out on that
one.
WOLVERINE VS.
YAKUZA
Hugh Jackman’s unforgettable take on the
hyper popular Marvel hero has lasted over
15 years now, and the creative well doesn’t
appear to be drying up anytime soon.
The Wolverine was a substantial improvement
on Logan’s first solo outing, drawing on
the character’s comic book roots to serve
up a fresh take on the face of the X-Men franchise.
This fight sequence aboard a high speed train
against a few insanely determined Yakuza was
eye openingly innovative, and deserved far
more praise than it received.
That being said, the scene is not quite our
favorite locomotive based Marvel brawl…
What did you think of our list?
Will the Batman/Superman brawl have earned
its way on here when all is said and done,
or will it be outshined by the Civil War showdown
between Captain America and Iron Man?
Sound off in the comments below, and be sure
to subscribe to our channel for more videos
like this one.